Powerful cosmic rays smash through
spaceships.
But how can objects smaller than an atom?
Carry enough energy to be dangerous to
astronauts?
Moving objects carry energy.
We call this kinetic energy.
And when they strike something, they
transform that energy.
When I hit my hand, the kinetic energy of my
fist transforms into sound and heat and
vibration. My hand hurts a little from that
impact from the transformation of energy.
It's the same thing with cosmic rays.
When they slam into a human brain cell or a
computer chip, they dump some energy causing
damage. How much damage depends on their
kinetic energy.
And that comes down to two things mass and
speed.
Intuitively, things that are moving at the
same speed.
If they're more massive, they carry more
energy.
A bigger asteroid slamming into Earth will
do more damage than a smaller asteroid.
If you double the mass of an object, its
kinetic energy also doubles.
Although mass is important, it's not as
important as speed.
Speed matters even more than mass.
The kinetic energy depends directly on the
mass, but it depends on the square of the
speed. Here's what that means.
You double the mass, you have double the
kinetic energy.
You double the speed you have four times the
When it comes to speed.
Cosmic rays are the elite.
An ultra high energy cosmic ray detected in
1991 hit the atmosphere so fast, scientists
called it the Oh, my God particle.
This particle was higher energy than they
thought they would ever, ever see.
Until this fluorescent streak in the Utah
sky.
No one believed the particle could reach the
earth, traveling so close to the speed of
light, making cosmic ray particles far more
dangerous than expected.
As you approach the speed of light energy
momentum mass, they start to act a little bit
differently.
Einstein's equations of relativity become
important.
The physics changes and the energy it has
becomes much, much, much stronger.
If a particle is moving at close to the speed
of light, that means that its energy is
almost at the maximum allowed by the laws of
physics.
It's amazing to think that something as tiny
as a proton could actually be dangerous to
human being. But amazingly, that proton is
moving so fast it carries as much energy as a
baseball thrown at a hundred miles an hour.
A baseball contains over 1,000,000,000,000
trillion protons.
Imagine all that energy carried by just one
particle.
So now you get a sense of just how risky
these can be.
Ultra high energy cosmic rays like the oh my
God, particle are like supersonic missiles.
They are the fastest, but they're so rare.
Astronauts are unlikely to be hit by one.
Solar cosmic rays are like baby pellets.
Abundant, but our spacecraft can block them.
The biggest threat to our astronauts,
however, are galactic cosmic rays.
They come from elsewhere in the Milky Way.
The combination of their speed and frequency
makes them the most dangerous.
These galactic cosmic rays are much more
powerful than the solar cosmic rays, and
they've traveled enormous distances to mess
you up.
Luckily, our astronauts have a surprising
protector, a guardian of the solar system,
the sun.
As well as spitting out these high energy
solar cosmic ray particles.
The sun is also streaming out lots of much
lower energy particles of the solar wind.
That outward moving solar wind acts as a
force field in the cosmic rays have to work
their way upstream to get to Earth far
inside this bubble.
The solar wind extends 11 billion miles
around the solar system, generating a
magnetic field that repels incoming galactic
cosmic rays.
It's almost like the deflector shield of the
Starship Enterprise.
So the sun's magnetic field partially helps
protect the Earth and any astronauts from the
incoming radiation.
Not long ago, our Voyager spacecraft made it
to that boundary between the sun's bubble and
the galaxy and was able to study that
region.
And we see the difference between inside the
sun's bubble and what's going on outside the
sun's bubble. The sun has our back billions
of miles away, and that's pretty cool.
The Voyager space probes discovered a moving
battlefield.
The solar wind behaves a bit like a storm
front on Earth.
Sometimes it advances.
Sometimes it retreats.
When the sun's activity is the highest, it's
spitting out more solar energetic protons.
But those solar cosmic rays are much less
damaging than the galactic ones.
So the net is a benefit.
So actually, ironically, you might find that
the astronauts, it is safer to launch
missions to Mars during a period of higher
solar activity because although you have more
of the solar particle radiation, you also
get a better shielding effect from the solar
wind.
The sun's activity goes through an 11 year
cycle of highs and lows.
The protective bubble follows the same
cycle, allowing NASA to predict the safest
times to launch.
This is a thorny problem and we have very
smart people working on it, but we want to
explore space as much as we can, but we have
to lower the risk to the astronauts as much
as possible.
Nasa's fight against the cosmic invaders
continues, But the biggest mystery remains
what exactly is launching the deadliest
galactic cosmic rays?
Every second quadrillions of bits of space,
shrapnel, race towards Earth at close to the
speed of light.
Galactic cosmic rays.
The galactic cosmic rays are like a rifle
bullet.
You do not want to get hit by one of these.
They are invaders from outside the solar
system.
We know they're made by something powerful
within our galaxy.
So the source should be easy to detect.
You'd think if one of them hits a detector on
Earth that we'd just be able to point back in
a straight line and say it came from over
there.
And then look, is there something else over
there like a supernova explosion that could
explain the source of this?
The problem is that cosmic rays get bent as
they move by magnetic fields.
The electric charge on a cosmic ray makes it
act like a little magnet, and the Milky Way
is full of other magnets.
If I'm a cosmic ray just barreling through
the galaxy and I encounter a magnetic field,
I'm going to slightly change directions.
Maybe here, maybe there, maybe up there.
My trajectory is going to become scrambled.
And after a few million years or so,
basically all the information about where it
started has been lost. It's going in a
completely random direction for all practical
purposes.
But galactic cosmic rays also have a
sidekick, one that is far less elusive.
Gamma rays.
When a galactic cosmic ray hits a regular
atom out in space, it causes this big
reaction.
In amidst all sorts of other particles,
including gamma rays, which are basically
extremely energetic photons of light.
Critically, gamma rays don't get bent by
magnetic fields because they don't have an
electric charge, so they just beeline off in
a straight line along whatever direction the
cosmic ray was moving in in the first place.
So we can look back at where gamma rays are
coming from in the sky.
And that tells us where there are a lot of
cosmic rays having collisions.
And they've led us to a prime suspect.
Supernovas.
Supernova are some of the most powerful
explosions in the universe.
And so they're ripe grounds for these highly
energetic, extremely fast particles to be
created.
When a giant star runs out of fuel, it can no
longer support its own weight.
It collapses inward.
Triggering a huge explosion, powerful enough
to smash atoms into tiny pieces.
The explosion pushes out an expanding cloud
of gas and dust.
The supernova remnant.